Moody gloomy and chillier than the
Hudson River in wintertime Netflix's
clever new detective Thriller the pale
blue eye builds to a stunning and
emotional twist
the big twist and the pale blue eye
which Poe helpfully spells out for us in
a monologue is that Landor is the killer
of both Cadets fry and Ballinger fry
Ballinger and a third Cadet named
Stoddard sexually assaulted Landorus
daughter Maddie years before the events
of the movie Maddie managed to grab
Fry's dog tag which led Landor to
eventually lure him to the woods with a
note and strangle him prize diary in
turn gave Lander the identity of the
other two attackers after he killed
Ballinger Stoddard ran away fearing for
his life after piecing together
scattered information about how Maddie
had run off from the townsfolk poe
realizes the Killer's true identity when
he compares the notelander left for him
with a scrap of paper found in the dead
Fry's hand the pale blue eye turns on an
enormous coincidence that Landor would
be called to investigate prize murder
mere hours after committing it himself
but as many characters notes his
reputation as a crime solver precedes
him is it true you want to listen to the
confession with nothing more than
piercing look
Landor is able to get away with murder
in large part because of the actions of
the Marquis family perhaps the most
Gothic American family not named Adams
daughter Leah suffers from a falling
disease epilepsy in modern day terms and
her father Dr Marquis has exhausted all
of 1830s medicine attempting to treat it
finally with his Blessing and the
participation of Leah's creepy brother
Artemis and high strung mother Julia the
family has turned to devil worship to
treat her symptoms I sacrificed
everything for my Leah
I then object to her finding a cure
elsewhere as Lander and Poe learned via
a book of Arcane information about
witches they require a heart from a
hanged man for their magic so the night
fry is killed Artemis uses his uncle's
old officer's coat to dismiss the cadet
guarding the body and remove its heart
throwing everyone off Landorus Trail
Landor later removes Ballinger's heart
and the hearts of local livestock to
give Credence to the perception that
there's a Madman on the loose
one of the chief pleasures of the pale
blue eyes the way it exists as a
Pastiche of what we know will be
recurring themes in the real Edgar Allan
Poe's work I've learned more in rooms
like this than any classroom you could
think of the film as sort of a prequel
or superhero origin story for Poe his
brief and doomed romance with Leah
inspires him to recite a poem a
fictional one by novelist Lewis Bayard
that references both Lenore and the pale
blue eye that gives the story its title
Endless Night caught her then in its
slurry shrouding all but a pale blue art
the name of Lenore was often used by
real world Poe in his work usually when
a poem's narrator mentions a doomed lost
love over the course of his life Poe
lost his birth mother adopted mother and
wife to premature deaths so Leah fits
right into a pattern of pale sickly
Muses for pose macop work it's no wonder
that it's love at first sight the phrase
pale blue eye appears in Poe's short
story The Tell-Tale Heart in reference
to the murder victim whose heart drives
the narrator mad from beneath the
floorboards so ascribing it to Leah and
the pale blue eye foreshadows her
premature death in and grizzly
association with excised hearts
the morning after Ballinger attacks Poe
in the woods for his interest in Leah
he's found hanged and mutilated this
casts suspicion on Poe who is
understandably angry but it's yet
another red herring as we learn Landor
killed the arrogance and aggressive
Cadets but what's inexplicable is the
fact that Ballinger didn't destroy Fry's
diary which implicated him in the attack
on Maddie by sending it to Fry's mother
instead of just burning it Ballinger
marked himself for a brutal death we
don't get to know Ballinger particularly
well so we don't know what motivates him
to send the diary to Fry's mother along
with a note that implies she may wish to
burn it there's no way he could have
known that she would instead innocently
hand it over to the very man that killed
her son then come after him but it's at
best unwise to leave it out there
although the pale blue eye has been
modestly successful with critics the
performances of Christian Bale and Harry
melling have been overlooked this award
season in a dense screenplay that
reveals little of either character's
inner life the bond between the retired
detective and the odd young Cadets is
given depth and warmth by the actors
Harry melling well beyond my imagination
bringing the poe that I envisioned to
life and it really hits when Poe
realizes he's been used by landlord to
frame the Marquis family for his
misdeeds it's a shocking betrayal but
it's not entirely clear why Landor
enlisted Poe's assistance to begin with
when he learns Fry's heart has gone
missing land or perhaps intuitively
realizes that the organ thieves might
provide him the exact cover he needs to
kill his daughter's other attackers he
then recruits the Bright Young poet
hoping that he was clever enough to
solve that mystery but not so clever
that he would put the entire situation
together it nearly worked but in letting
his guard down about Maddie he revealed
too much to his new protege
the pale blue eye maintains an
unsettling Aura of Mystery by never
revealing exactly what the Marquis
family does with the stolen Hearts it's
some sort of a cult ritual that involves
a magic circle and leaves a fair amount
of blood behind Dr Marquis believes his
daughter is communion with the spirits
of the Dead epilepsy has historically
been associated with seeing visions and
hearing voices and many contemporary
psychiatrists believe Joan of Arc
suffered from it but he doesn't think
his children are capable of murder
luckily for Landor they graduate to
attempted murder and are on the verge of
cutting outposts still beating heart
when he discovers them in the ice house
even more conveniently both Leah and
Artemis die in the ensuing fire when a
candle gets knocked over the siblings
assume the blame for Landorus crimes as
they're no longer alive to defend
themselves
there comes a point in the pale blue eye
when it appears a Poe himself might be
the murderer it's almost obligatory in a
story where a legendarily death obsessed
figure like Poe is a major character
after all his dead mother dictates poems
to him while he sleeps my mother has a
kind of
presence in my life
my sleepings and my Awakenings and the
film opens with a quote from the real
poem using the boundaries which divide
life from Death are at best shadowy and
vague who's to say where one ends and
where the other begins but it's
ultimately just a brief misdirect when
we find out that Poe lied about having
dealings with the deceased fry in the
past coming on the heels of Ballinger's
murder after he and Pope fought it seems
like Poe might be settling personal
vendettas but Landor is skeptical even
when the West Point bosses insist on
Poe's arrest and takes Poe at his word
when he sheepishly admits that Frye was
just one of the plethora of fellow
Cadets that had bullied him for his
awkward bookish ways in the past year if
he killed every bully at West Point the
academy would be virtually empty
in movies it's not always a bad thing to
commune with the dead perhaps you can
party with them like in Beetlejuice or
maybe your dead mother writes poetry for
you pose does in the pale blue eye but
Leah Mark was his mentor from the other
side her great great grandfather Henry
Leclerc prefers blood sacrifice in
another of the story's astonishing
coincidence is the very same
misunderstood devil worshiping witch
hunter Leclerc that Lander's friend Jean
Pepe mentions turns out to be a direct
ancestor the Marquis family the other
witch hunter and demonologist Jean Pepe
mentions Pierre de lankra did exist and
preside over Mass witch trials in 17th
century France but was reviled for
practicing the witch's Sabbath the exact
sort of occult ritual that inspired the
Marquis family like the work of the real
Edgar Allan Poe the pale blue eye
explores the thin line between religious
piety and communing with death itself
with an emphasis on the macabre Edgar
Allan Poe is probably most famous for
his poetry made iconic for a new
generation of audiences thanks to the
Pitch Perfect interpretation of the
Raven in a Treehouse of Horror
installment of The Simpsons
[Music]
but he's also credited with inventing
the genre of detective fiction before
Sherlock Holmes Miss smart bowl or Aku
Poirot pose inspector C August dupant
appeared in his 1841 short story the
murders in the room more and established
all the Hallmarks of the detective story
before the word detective was even in
regular use this knowledge adds a fun
and touching subtext to the pale blue
eye at one point while drinking together
in the Local Tavern Poe clearly excited
to be working with the renowned
inspector Landor makes a bold claim I
should write a poem someday
something that shall send your name down
through the ages for the 20 year old and
as yet unsuccessful character a dreamer
it's an ambitious promise but from our
perspective it's easy to trace the name
Augustus Landor to see August dupant and
imagine it is a tribute to an old friend
the movie's pose seemingly goes on to
immortalize landro's deductive logic and
prose not quite poetry leaving out as
murderous Tendencies for good measure
after Poe's speech piecing the whole
puzzle together followed by landor's
weary confession Poe asks a heavy
question
clandor leaves the decision up to his
new Young friend pointing out that he
holds the only evidence that links him
to the murders of fry and Ballinger in
the form of the notes that land or left
before fry impo himself wordlessly Poe
burns the evidence and resolves to let
landlord Go free causing the exhausted
grief-stricken father to break into
tears of anguished belief as an orphan
haunted by death himself po perhaps
knows that the acts of murder that
Landorus committed will haunt him more
than any kind of societal Justice ever
will it's a heavy quietly devastating
scene as the act of Mercy is
overshadowed by the Grim nature of what
Landor has been through as well as the
sad fact opposed to partying his life
for Good In Another Life Landorus
speculates aloud Maddie might have run
into Poe the night of the ball instead
of her assailants and he'd have a happy
daughter and son-in-law instead of a
life built with death and sadness
Christian Bale and Harry melling as
Landor and Poe respectively equipped
themselves spectacularly well weeping
silent tears in turn as The Melancholy
becomes too much for them to bear
the pale blue eye draws to a close with
Landor returning to the Cliff's Edge
where Maddie lept to her dad with his
wife and daughter dead and Maddie's
attacker is either dead or On the Run
Landor faces an uncertain future Poe has
spared him even the mixed Solace of
wasting away in prison so it's natural
to suspect he's considering joining his
daughter in death like the ending of The
Sopranos it's impossible to know exactly
what happens after the movie cuts to
black but it seems like the pale blue
eye airs on the side of Hope with a calm
voice sandor releases one of Maddie's
ribbons into the wind and finally says
goodbye rest my love the events of the
movie have left with him some semblance
of closure especially the decision not
to pursue stodder which signals
acceptance on Landorus part more than it
does despair perhaps influenced by Poe's
unique views on the thin veil between
life and death he feels no need to hurry
his own demise and join his family
foreign